welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
standardization of cell viability assays
in primary cells as a prerequisite for
novel bio processing applications
presented by dr. Simon kaya assistant
professor of Ophthalmology and molecular
pharmacology and therapeutics Loyola
University of Chicago
my name is execute ears and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking and web site and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. kaya
Owen I'll turn the presentation over to
him hello everyone and thank you for
joining this presentation and thank you
sorry for the kind introduction before I
begin my presentation I'd like to make
you aware of two financial disclosures
I'm shareholder and board member of
can't be scientific LLC and also
shareholder member of the executive
leadership team at experimental limited
however I will not be discussing
discussing any commercial applications
today so there is no conflict in any
components of the presentation to start
off with let's consider the bio
processing pipeline for medicinal
formulations traditionally the pipeline
will begin with cell line development we
followed by upstream processing
downstream processing that often
involves any kind of purification etc
the formulation development and
ultimately the process analytics leading
to of therapeutic in today's
presentation we will focus on the first
component highlighted here in the red
box the cell line development when we
think about medicinal bio processing
there are a lot of what I would term
classic applications that were well
familiar with many of these involve
suspension cell lines such as Chinese
hamster ovary cells or cho cells and
they used for the production of many
protein based drugs some prominent
examples here are factor 7 for blood
clotting insulin and many others more
recently we've also seen an advancement
in the generation of antibody-based
drugs where it's essentially suspension
cell cultures are used to synthesize and
purify immunoglobulins however new
advances in the research and science
have led to novel applications that
require bio processing applications one
such example is a generation of exosome
based medicines and I'll talk a little
bit about exercise in the next couple of
slides fizzy includes are also
personalized medicine therapies that
rely on stem cells as well as other
specialized cell types such as
astrocytes
and neurons so we see a need for primary
cell culture and the following
optimization for downstream processes
one example I'd like to give you today
is the generation of bioengineered
exosomes exosomes
or extracellular b vesicles v's are
secreted from essentially all cells the
very small membrane bound particles in
the nanometer size range and they carry
unique cargo this cargo can consist of
micro RNA RNA DNA protein and many
others however the critical component
here is that exosome cargo depends on
the cell type so different cell types
actually secrete exosomes or
extracellular
it calls with very unique and distinct
components but it is this card or these
components that are considered to exert
the therapeutic effect so if we're
considering the use of exosomes
and bioengineering them to contain a
specified and predefined cargo we need
to optimize primary cell culture and the
following downstream processes in order
to make these extracellular vesicles of
exosomes amenable to become therapeutics
my research group at Loyola University
Chicago focuses on exosomes for the
treatment of glaucoma glaucoma is a very
prevalent neurodegenerative disease that
comes that affects almost three million
people in the United States being an
age-related disorder together with an
aging population we anticipate that this
disease will increase to a prevalence of
over four million people by 2030 a
particular relevant certain populations
of much higher risk to develop glaucoma
whose includes African Americans of age
40 or older and especially
mexican-americans and essentially
everybody over the age of 60 in glaucoma
the cell type that's affected optic
nerve had astrocytes as you can see on
the picture on the right you see a
fundus image of a healthy optic nerve
similar to what your family gist would
see when he lives into a healthy eye on
the right part of the picture you see an
optic nerve in an eye that suffers from
glaucoma as you can see in the central
portion the white area is much disturbed
and this is the region where these optic
nerve or astrocytes are located our
approach is to try to isolate exosomes
and other therapeutic identify
therapeutics that they can target these
specific cells for this we actually need
to optimize the primary culture of these
cells in order to establish
cost-effective high sensitivity and high
efficacy bio processing applications
this light just gives you a quick
overview over a typical culture
procedure in contrast to cell lines
where cell stock is frozen down primary
cells have to be isolated from direct
ition material that can be obtained from
an individual patient or in the case of
astrocytes we can use donor or cadaver
material to generate these in order to
isolate therapeutics in the future in
this case this is a rather laborious
process of identifying and isolating the
small region of the optic nerve head on
the eyeball which is depicted and the
schematic diagram at the bottom and then
isolating these cells in primary cell
culture but they will grow out of the
optic nerve and form a monolayer culture
of high purity one important component
of optimization of these primary cell
cultures our selves I ability and
proliferation assays they really serve
the purpose to determine the effect of
treatments and also culture conditions
on cell viability this becomes important
when we use drugs or therapies such as
cytokines oxidative stress to modify the
exosome cargo that is secreted from
these cells also so viability can be
affected by the cell media and
supplements used to grow and maintain
these cells we can also use cell
viability assays to quantify the rate of
proliferation which is of critical
importance for the scalability and
efficacy of bio processing two of the
most popular and widely used cell
viability and proliferation assays of
the empty TSA and the lactate
dehydrogenase assay the MTT assay an
empty T stands for three four five
dimethyl fires or - I'll - five - all
tetrazolium bromide or short mt t it's
based on the conversion of M DT to the
colored dye formers on
MTT when placed on life cells can be
taken up into the mitochondria of the
cells and inside the cells and enzyme
mitochondrial reductase will convert MDT
to form as an the purple product of
formers and can then be detected
spectrophotometric Lee on the left you
see an example of primary cells that
have been exposed to increasing levels
of oxidative stress using a hydrogen
peroxide analog t bhp as you can see in
an increasing concentrations of T bhp
needs to decrease in the absorption this
reflects a loss of mitochondrial
reductase activity in mitochondria and
is a correlate of cell survival very
similarly the lactate dehydrogenase
release sa is relying on a tetrazolium
compound in the living cell lactate
dehydrogenase catalyzes the reaction
from lactate to pyruvate and using NAD+
NADH converts pyruvate to IO tone nitro
tetrazolium which is then converted to
formers and using deferens in a living
cell in the body or in organs like that
dehydrogenase is secreted into the
bloodstream and cell culture we can
measure lactate dehydrogenase in the
media supernatant
therefore the LDH release si has the
advantage that it can be used for both
adren and suspension cell cultures
furthermore it can be very readily
adopted to primary cells but why
optimize LDH release assays it's a
well-established assays and their
numerous commercial solutions they are
standard protocols for many routine
applications however one of the major
drawbacks of commercial LDH release
assays is that they're very costly and
they also have limited options for
optimization
what I will present you today is the
development of a custom LDH assay it has
known components and a very small number
and thereby provides greater options for
optimization and the flexibility to
adjust the SI to your specific
experimental needs in addition it is 20
to 30 times cheaper than commercial
options and in addition the SI is
readily scalable from our typical
96-well assays all the way to true
high-throughput applications our group
has published several manuscripts
describing the LDH release assay that
are listed here the first one initially
validating the assay on cell lines then
moving into primary astrocyte culture
and in the last article providing
detailed step-by-step protocols
including troubleshooting tips for
primary astrocyte cultures and primary
neuronal cultures later in this
presentation I will discuss both the
individual steps as well as some of the
troubleshooting that can occur with
these assays as it is being adapted for
primary cells we have designed our
custom LDH release assay you can obtain
a minimum of solutions and reagents
essentially there are four solutions
that are needed but for a and buffer B
are combined in equal volumes and
contain all the components to catalyze
the reaction the supplement is added in
order to provide the color reaction and
having the supplement as a separate
reagent allows the titration for very
small or larger amounts of lactate
dehydrogenase that is being released
into the particular media for a given
application the stop solution is merely
1 molar acetic acid that serves to stop
the reaction and provide ample time for
subsequent analysis for a 96-well plate
based assay the diagrams depict the
typical workflow of adding a drug
or any kind of media letting the cells
incubate for buried amounts of time
anywhere from a few hours to overnight
then collecting the supernatant in a new
plate adding the lactate dehydrogenase
assay components that have been
pre-mixed and consists of buffer a
buffer B and the supplement and then
following adjustment optimization of the
incubation time which is typically
anywhere between thirty minutes and two
hours stopping the reaction with acetic
acid and measuring the absorbance at 499
a meters wavelength here I'm showing you
our initial validation of our customer
say compared to the cytotoxic 96 assay
which is a commercially available
solution the cells we used on this one
were initially a cell line c6 ester
glioma cells that we treated with
oxidative stress in the gray lines you
can see the untreated cells and in dark
gray cells treated with the vehicle
which in this case was point one percent
ethanol in orange you'll see cells that
will also treat it with an antioxidant
troll ox which is the prototypical item
any analogue and very potent superoxide
dismutase scavenger on the x axis you
see increasing concentrations of
tert-butyl hydrogen peroxide and most
water stable analog of hydrogen peroxide
as you can see as cells suffer from
oxidative stress and reduce the
viability you see in significant
increase in LDH release which can be
potent Lee predicted prevented by troll
ons as you can also appreciate there is
no difference in sensitivity or efficacy
of our assets compared to the commercial
situation in this graph I've overlaid
the untreated cell graphs for our
customers as well as the commercial
assay and you put the pricing and the
scale of
into perspective while our custom essay
on average cost about $1 20 commercial
solutions typically average of 30 to 50
dollars per plate providing a
significant cost saving which is in
addition to the advantages of better
flexibility in terms of optimization and
scalability in our article from 2017
we've also provided protocols call this
essay can be adapted to culture read
cortical neurons as well as two primary
cultured optic nerve for astrocytes
again here you see untreated cells which
are depicted in the breadline label
control or treated with troll logs as an
antioxidant but you can appreciate as a
right shift in the curve making the
cells the cells less susceptible to the
latias effects of oxidative stress for
bio processing one important
consideration is the optimization of
media formulations different media's are
required a different media can contain
different different formulations
different amino acids different amounts
of sugar and primary cells are much less
resistant to exogenous stresses as many
cell lines so here it is important to
actually optimize the media formulation
and the lactate dehydrogenase release si
provides one very simple option to do
that what I'm showing you here is an
analysis of lactate dehydrogenase
release compared to a control media for
10 different media compositions and as
you can see some of the media's for
example 3 or 6 or 10 show significant
levels of lactate dehydrogenase release
this is an indicator that cells are
undergoing apoptosis not dying or at
least are stressed this can have
deleterious effects on any subsequent
bio processing application so optimizing
yourself culture using a media
formulation that is suitable to the
cells and provides man
survival will provide much better
efficacy in the downstream bio
processing applications furthermore the
lactate dehydrogenase release si can be
used for toxicities training one example
is a traditional toxicity testing for
the development of nutriceuticals
however as we're talking about X's ohms
and utilizing exosome populations to
serve as therapeutics supplementation's
of cells with nutraceutical compounds or
antioxidants or any other drugs can
modify for example the antioxidant
potential of these cells and thereby
create a unique cargo in our exosomes
yeah I'm showing you an example of using
human corneal epithelial cells that were
treated reserved for you more something
you all is a plant derived antioxidant
that occurs in the hospital in a top
panel labeled a you see an MD TSA with
increasing concentrations of xanthohumol
we're seeing a loss in cell viability at
high doses of about 50 and 100
micromolar this is reflected and very
well tested with lactate with elected
dehydrogenase assay I'm comparing here
both the lactate dehydrogenase as the
empty empty tsa the advantage of the MTT
assay is that it is suitable for both a
current as well as suspension cell lines
whereas the MTT assay is traditionally
used Lateran cells which makes it less
flexible for by a processing application
however what I hope you can appreciate
is the fact that both assays provide
very similar results making the lactate
dehydrogenase assay given its
flexibility and cost and options for
optimization the preferred option also
the lactate dehydrogenase release at
said the way we've developed it provides
a lot of options
troubleshooting and optimizing it to
your specific needs and the specific
cell line or primary cell that you're
working with I want to go through some
of the problems their causes and their
solutions as these are very universal
and can be applied to very many
different cell types obviously the
biggest problem is if there is low or no
signal that is often related to very low
density that can occur in early bio
processing before optimization has taken
place obviously the solution here is to
either increase the seeding density or
to have a higher concentration of cells
per volume also test compounds or media
may inhibit lactate dehydrogenase
activity given that our assay contains
so few reagent it makes it very easy to
actually test in a standardized setting
that might be self free to actually see
whether any component interferes with
the enzyme activity itself media
optimization is also important as many
media that we're using in bio processing
applications contain sodium pyruvate
sodium pyruvate is very well known
inhibitor flecked that you hydrogenate
so therefore avoiding media with sodium
pyruvate is often necessary to prevent
any confounding effects when conducting
the LDH release si also the incubation
time for the si might be too short and
it's easy to conduct a kinetic gram and
monitor LDH release over time an example
of such experimental design is provided
in our publication from 2015 that's
referenced here you will also find these
tables in our publication from 2017 that
have referenced on earlier slide little
reference again on my final slide
another problem that is often
encountered is a too high background
signal or signals that is being
saturated obviously here
the cell concentration might be too high
and as in the previous step with too low
signal optimizing seating densities can
resolve this problem however sometimes
the intrinsic lactate dehydrogenase
activity in the serum or in the media is
high what's possible here is to reduce
the serum concentration or often readily
achieved by reducing the concentration
of a supplement typically we use
supplement at a 1 in 10,000 dilution but
it can be easily eluded to one in 20,000
or one in 50,000 also heat and
activation may affect the serum LDH
activity typically we would recommend
testing the endogenous activity of the
serum by performing a cell-free or serum
free and media controls complete medium
LDH activity is typically similar to the
observed LDH activity of untreated cells
so that makes the experimental design
very easy also the target signal might
be too high or saturated this is often
the problem with commercial assay where
there's limited options for optimization
again here our assay allows to adjust
the concentration of the MP ms
supplement again as previously it can be
readily diluted to 1 in 20,000 or even 1
in 50,000 which is a much simpler
solution than having to adjust the
workflow and alluding the precious
sample material that is being used for
the assay by doing another step that
would require Sen an operating procedure
really the die might turn yellow after
addition of the stop solution this
typically indicates that the constraint
concentration of acetic acid is too high
the reduced dye which is normally purple
for farmers and can spontaneously
oxidize back to its initial reactant
which is like yellow when the pH reaches
levels of lower than 4
you can either reduce the amount of stop
solution and of course easily test the
pH after adding sub solution using a pH
strip or pH meter and ensuring that the
pH stays above 4.0 so in summary normal
bio processing applications may require
the use of primary entrant and Sesenta
suspension cell cultures such as
astrocytes fibroblasts and neuronal
cells an app tation of bio processing to
the use of primary cells requires
optimization optimization of culture
conditions for different cell types is
critical and primary cells are very
different requirements and cell lines
making this much more challenging task
this optimization requires as a
development for the use of cell
viability and proliferation assay for
this the lactate dehydrogenase release
si is a well-established assays that can
quantify very subtle changes in cell
survival which is critical in
identifying potential confounding
problems on utilizing these for future
bio processing and downstream
applications Oh al DHS a can be
developed as a very cost-effective and
customizable assay becomes itself known
components it's got a strong flexibility
for optimization as I've shown you this
presentation it's about twenty to thirty
times cheaper than commercial solutions
and it is very readily scalable again
down here I've listed the three
publications that have referred to in
today's presentation together with the
pubmed ID numbers so you can easily
retrieve them on PubMed lastly I'd like
to acknowledge the funding sources that
have supported the research in my lab
over the last few years including
glaucoma foundation the John and Therese
Mulcahy endowed professorship in
ophthalmology at Loyola University
Chicago several other of our foundation
partners the Department of Veterans
Affairs as well as experimental limited
experimenting is a contract research
organization
so we work very closely in asset
development and also thanks to my
collaborators in Chicago in Kansas City
my name of Peter cool an experiment in
Finland and of course
none of this work would have been done
without the excellent lab members and
staff members that I have in my group
and I'd like to acknowledge particularly
Nicci Ghosh and Harsha Arianny who have
contributed a lot to the work I've shown
you today again thank you very much for
your attention
and for your interest in today's
presentation and I look forward to
receiving your questions and answering
them by email thank you very much thank
you dr. kaya for that invitation
I would also like to thank labrys for
making today's educational webcast
possible now before we go I want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April of 2019 as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now we hope to see you
again soon thank you sure bye